[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité la question du
port de l'uniforme à l'école revient
régulièrement en cette période de
rentrée scolaire en Martinique la
question ne se pose plus depuis depuis
longtemps la rédaction de via ATV a posé
la question aux intéressés et c'est
surprenant vous verrez nous le
constatons tous à la pompe le carburant
reste cher l'annonce par l'état de la
fin des aides aux professionnels fait
craindre le pire aux pêcheurs de
l'Orient ils ont été rencontrés par les
équipes de TB Sud dans un instant en
Champagne la récolte du raisin a dû être
réalisée à marche forcée face à des
alléas climatique qui aurait pu être
préjudiciable à la qualité du futur
nectar la rédaction de Canal 32 a pu
goûter les premiers jus la qualité est
finalement au rendez-vous vous verrez
historiquement la ville de nîes a occupé
une place stratégique dans l'histoire de
l'empire romain après de longues
démarches sa célèbre Maison Carrée est
enfin inscrite au patrimoine mondial de
l'humanité par l'UNESCO un moment
d'émotion partagé avec nos partenaires
de via
Occitanie revenons tout d'abord dans ce
journal sur la visite historique du pape
à Marseille samedi dernier si Audren et
régie sanouille n'ont pu se rendre dans
la cité faussée
pour assister à la messe du pape
François ce couple de vigneron
d'ambiierle dans le nord de la Loire a
tout de même vécu un weekend de félicité
car c'est un de leur vin de la côte
ranaise que le Pape a porté à ses lèvres
lors de la messe au stade Vélodrome
céineercilia les a rencontré pour TL7
regardz donc nous sommes sur la parcelle
qui de d'une vigne de 50 ans vous voyez
on l'amène il y a de l'enerbement
naturel il y a beaucoup d'herbes il y a
beaucoup de choses qui poussent dans nos
vignes c'est sur cette petite parcelle
de vigne qui a été récolter le raisin de
la QV 2020 le mésime lodatossi qui sera
servi sur la table du pape lors de son
dîner privé à Marseille un peu avantc
c'est un vin blanc du domaine qui sera
consacré lors de la messe des vins
donnés gracieusement par ce couple de
vigneron reconverti un changement de vie
qu'il doivent aussi au discours du Pape
sur l'écologie intégrale et la réponse a
été positive à notre grande surprise ça
s'est fait très simplement il nous a dit
banco voilà et donc
c'est c'est vrai que c'est une grande
joie parce que j'imagine que pour des
vigirons catholiques c'est c'est c'est
un peu l'apogé de voir votre vin porter
sur l'hôtel Régis et od reen anouille
travaillent leur terre sans intervention
mécanique une viticulture qui est comme
ils le disent l'expression de la vie
dans leur sol le vin n'est pas seulement
un breuvage mais tout un symbole de leur
foi ce n'est pas que du jus de raisin
fermenté c'est c'est quelque chose de
beaucoup c'est c'est une symbolique qui
est extrêmement forte le le raisin pour
devenir vain il doit mourir à lui-même
il doit mourir pour se transformer en
vain pour ressusciter renaître en vain
et et cette symbolique effectivement de
la de la mort et la Renaissance en tant
que chrétien que catholique vous
comprenez qu'elle peut nous tenir à cœur
mais sur un plan d'un point de vue
humain tout simplement voilà elle vous
porte dans une dimension verticale que
que chacun peut partager ce couple ne
pourra pas se déplacer pour assister ce
samedi à la messe mais ils sont fiers de
participer à le manière à ce moment
sacré quelques jours après la rentrée
scolaire on revient sur la question de
l'école et de l'uniforme et si en
métropole le sujet fait toujours débat
ce n'est plus le cas en Martinique où le
port de l'uniforme scolaire et la norme
dans les collèges et les lycée polo aux
couleurs de leur établissement
accompagné d'un jean ou d'une jupe les
élèves portent tous la même tenue alors
au-delà du côté pratique beaucoup
mettent en avant l'uniforme comme
vecteur d'égalité mais est-ce vraiment
le cas élément de réponse avec que Ryan
anehas pour via ATV regardez il est
visible aux quatre coins de l'île et
obligatoire dans presque tous les
établissements l'uniforme fait partie
intégrante de la scolarité des enfants
martiniqués je pense que c'est une très
bonne chose parce que ça permet de
différencier un peu les élèves par
rapport aux intusions dans les écoles ça
permet de ne pas avoir de discrimination
entre les enfants tout le monde est
habillé pareil pour les parents c'est
beaucoup plus facile c'està-dire qu'on n
pas de question à se poser pour savoir
quel type de vêtement qu'on va donner
aux enfants pratique pour les parents
bon moyen de gommer les inégalités et de
stopper le harcèlement les avantages
sont nombreux pour les adeptes de
l'uniforme dans la salle des parents
d'élèves venus s'interroger face à un
chercheur en sciences social sur cette
pratique séculaire et la première
question d'où vient l'uniforme en
Martinique il y a personne qui a décidé
il y a pas un décideur qui a dit on va
une uniformiser tous les petits
martiniquais les petites martiniquaises
non il y a un établissement qui a
commencé un autre qui a suivi un autre
cas suivi et finalement il y a une une
mise en place progressive qui s'est
faite au point maintenant que tous les
établissements secondaires ou presque il
doit y en avoir un ou deux qui qui n'en
ont pas qui portent l'uniforme hormis le
haut et le bas les élèves peuvent
s'exprimer sur d'autres aspect
vestimentaire la tenue vestimentaire
réglementaire
finalement se matérialise sur un haut et
un bas après les élèves sont libres de
mettre les chaussures qu'ils veulent de
porter les sacs qu'ils veulent et se
différencier par ces éléments là aucun
texte de loi ne dispose de l'obligation
du port de l'uniforme sa question est
d'ailleurs en débat depuis plusieurs
mois dans
l'Hexagone voilà et noté que le nouveau
ministre de l'éducation nationale
Gabriel hatal ne voit pas une solution
miracle dans le port de l'uniforme à
l'école mais estime qu'une
expérimentation mérite d'être testé pour
faire avancer le débat fin de citation
il présentera son dispositif à l'automne
voilà toujours côté éducation avoir son
bac c'est bien trouver une place en
faculté sur parcours sup en revanche
relève encore du parcours du combattant
il y a 3 jours cristal a appris la
mauvaise nouvelle son dossier n'a pas
été retenu par l'Université Paris nanire
la bachelière de 18 ans originaire de
Compiègne qui a pourtant obtenu son bac
avec mention bien n'est inscrite nulle
part alors que la rentrée est déjà très
entamée la rédaction de 20 minutes l'a
rencontré pour nous
regarder bonjour je m'appelle Christal
j'ai 18 ans je bienent tout droit de
compienne je n'ai pas de fac aujourd'hui
et donc je suis venue à Paris pour faire
des démarches et rejoindre en fait l'UNF
cristal a raté sa rentrée il y a 3 jours
à la découverte sur parcours sup le
refus de son dossier par l'Université
Paris nanre la bachelière a fait appel à
l'UNEF elle a rendez-vous avec le
syndicat étudiants sur le campus
universitaire sa première fois à la fac
mais pas comme elle l'imaginait la jeune
fille de 18 ans espère encore trouver
une place en licence de sciences
politique si je suis là aujourd'hui
c'est vraiment pour me battre pour avoir
justement ma place à la fac parce que je
pense que tout le monde a le droit en
fait d'avoir sa place à l'université je
veux et j'ai toujours voulu étudier en
fait après le bac donc non je veux pas
lâcher maintenant l'université
parisanire a donné les raisons de ce
refus C c'était soit insuffisance
scolaire ou alorsah il y avait pas assez
de place à la fac donc ils ont pas pu me
donner mon
inscriptionêche ça va pour le
rassemblement ouais vraiment et pour se
faire entendre cristal distribue avec
ses camarades William et part des tract
en vue de rassemblement devant le
ministère de l'enseignement supérieur
pour mobiliser le plus de personnes et
pour vraiment montrer l'importance du
problème quoi au total ce sont 250
étudiants qui n'ont pas eu de place à
l'Université Paris nanre à la rentrée
sans transition nous aimons tous notre
factrice ou notre facteur pourtant en
Haute Savoie la Poste a du mal à
recruter face à la concurrence de la
Poste Suisse qui est toute proche elle
vient donc de lancer une grande campagne
visant à embaucher au moins 105 facteurs
et factrices sur l'ensemble du
territoire au savoyard Sébastien Germain
était à Tonon les Bains pour notre
partenaire h
Montblanc c'est l'heure de la tournée
pour Émilie lelon factrice à Tonon les
Bains depuis maintenant 5 ans en 2018 à
la suite de la liquidation de son salon
de coiffure la jeune femme tombe sur une
annonce de la Poste elle postule et
débute dès le lendemain un choix qu'elle
ne regrette absolument pas 5 ans plus
tard moi je suis super contente de mon
travail j'aime la liberté que ça que ça
laisse euh l'indépendance voilà par
rapport au fait qu'avant j'étais à mon
compte donc dans la coiffure c'est une
entreprise qui est hyper positive enfin
moi j'essaie d' d'influer vers ce ce de
ce sens-là pardon aujourd'hui ce que
j'aime c'est guider les nouvelles
nouveaux arrivants voilà les accueillir
au mieux des belles histoires comme
celles d'Émilie la Poste espère en vivre
encore plus grâce à son nouveau plan de
recrutement aujourd'hui 730 facteurs et
factrices officié en haut de sa voie
l'idée de cette campagne est donc de
faire grossir ce contingent en
s'adaptant aux contraintes déjà existant
nous avons une concurrence de la Suisse
qui a une politique salariale très
offensive et qui offre une capacité
d'emploi nous avons aussi comme toutes
les entreprises autour du la clément
nous sommes confrontés à un taux de
chômage en fait qui est très faible 5,2
% alors que le National est à 7,2 % et
puis nous avons aussi de sur ces deux
dernières années et bien connu une
augmentation très significative du
nombre d'emplois proposés cela crée un
tover important et donc pour nous nous
avons un besoin comme toutes les
entreprises qui s'est développé en fait
le Chel à travers la plateforme de
courrier colis de Tonon les Bains est
donc une des six zones prioritaires de
ce plan de recrutement et ici l'objectif
annoncé est de trouver au moins 60
nouveaux collaborateurs grâce notamment
à une formation accélérée et plusieurs
avantages en terme de rémunération il
s'agit pasant de de recruter en masse et
et et toutes les personnes qui suivent
mais par notre processus de recrutement
on a également une chargée de de
recrutement qui va avoir un entretien
approfondi c'est de trouver la la
personne qui a le projet qui correspond
à l'emploi qu'on propose et et éviter
d'avoir quelqu'un qui va partir dans un
an dans 2 ans et cetera au fil des
années le métier de facteur a bien
évolué et en France on a coutume de dire
qu'il est le deuxè personnage préféré
des français derrière le boulanger et
devant le pompier preuve qu'il a encore
de beau jours devant
lui trouver un emploi lorsque l'on
quitte l'univers carcéral n'est jamais
facile je vous propose de nous arrêter
un instant sur cette initiative
originale de la Fédération Française de
Tennis qui développe le concept urban
tennis si un cours a été installé dans
le centre de Limoge le second terrain a
été déployé lui et c'est une première à
l'intérieur même de la maison d'arrêt de
la ville une initiative qui aux yeux du
directeur de la prison participe
fortement à la resocialisation des
détenus il a répondu aux questions de
notre partenaire sur place de cette
alimage écoutez le sport c'est un
vecteur primordial incontournable pour
la réinsertion ou l'insertion des
détenus
et le sport il fait du bien à la tête et
au corps et et le temps au lieu de
passer du temps dans une cellule donc
les personnes détenues sortent pour se
défaouler ou pratiquer un sport on en
propose pas mal ici pas mal d'activités
sportives avec un moniteur de sport et
ça leur fait du bien
alheure où se tiennent les assise de la
pêche à Nice les pêcheurs continuent de
relever leur filet malgré une
rentabilité en nette baisse en raison du
coût élevé du gasoil la confirmation de
l'arrêt de l'IDE au carburant la semaine
dernière a fait tomber une chape de
plomb sur la filière qui dénonce
maintenant le désengagement de l'État
nous retrouvons Karine chevrolier pour
TB sud sur le port de l'Orient
regarde veille de départ pour petite
Mila mais avant de prendre la direction
des côtes espagnoles l'équipage va
compléter la cuve de gasoil la facture
sera partagée entre les quatre marins
aujourd'hui avec un prix du litre à 92
centimes elle va s'élever à près de
14000 € pour 15 tonnes c'est le
carburant nécessaire pour environ 10
jours de mer à l'heure d'aujourd'hui au
prix du gasoil il y a plus grandchose de
rentable c'est de la plus ou moins de la
survie quoi on paye nos affaires et
terminé on fait pas d'argent les gars
ont un salaire correct encore on paye
les traites du bateau les prêts et puis
sur l'armement on gagne pas d'argent du
tout mais pour le patron pêcheur
carburant et salaire ne sont que la
partie émergée des charges le coût des
matériaux a pris 30 % et à cela viennent
s'ajouter les imprévus comme l'achat
d'un nouveau moteur et un prêt de 200000
€ à contracté j'ai cassé mon moteur au
mois de juin j'ai B j'ai loupé ma saison
de langoustine j'ai mis un plus petit
moteur qui consomme moins justement pour
essayer de gagner un peu de à gauche à
droite quoi pour l'instant j'arrive à
maintenir la barque mais on verra bien
ce que l'avenir nous réserve quoi en
mars dernier l'aide gouvernementale au
carburant de 20 centimes permettait
d'éteindre le feu au sein de la
profession avec sa fin prévue le 15
octobre prochain un compréhension et
inquiétude mont sur les qu quand les
quotas de poisson baissent et leur prix
Scrier reste bas à partel quelques
espèces dit entre guillemets nobles qui
elles ont vu leur prix augmenter la
grande très grande majorité des espèces
est resté sur les mêmes prix depuis une
vingtaine d'années à l'inverse de des
autres professions n on peut pas
répercuter les coûts qu'on subit et le
fait que le poisson monte pas ça nous
handicape énormément ce vendredi
Alexandre Joan Christophe et Quentin
vont partir sans l'assurance d'une pêche
rentable au même moment le retour du
secrétaire d'État à la mre Hervé
Berville qui n'a pas communiqué depuis
l'annonce sera attendu par toute une
filière
avant de consacrer une large part de ce
journal au climat revenons sur la
situation au Maroc après le séisme
meurtrier qui a frappé la région d'azzou
au sud de Marrakech là-bas la diaspora
Corse n'est pas resté les bras croisés
et elle s'est fortement mobilisé afin de
venir en aide aux populations sinistré
initié par Johann Perrez originaire de
Coré et restaurateur à Marrakech la
mobilisation permet chaque jour
d'envoyer une dizaine de camions chargés
de produits de première nécessité dans
les endroits les plus inaccessibles de
la région un reportage de la chaîne
Corse télépaisé sur place regardez sur
un parking d'un grand distributeur de
Marrakech SEP camions attendent les
chargement des produits alimentaires des
légumes des tentes destinées aux
habitants des régions sinistrées tous
les jours depuis le séisme c'est le même
balai sur le même parking parmi les
bénévoles des Corses installés à
Marrakech l'association de bienfaiteurs
est né de l'urgence de la situation et
du besoin de structurer les aides une
trentaine de personnes se relèchent ch
jour pour charger les transporteurs
au-delà de la charge maximale parfois
jusqu'à 3 tonnes par camion à
l'initiative Johan et son groupe d'amis
solidaire vis-à-vis de ce pays qui l'a
accueilli pour lui ne rien faire n'est
pas une option on attend 500 matelas
également ramène électrogène des
projecteurs solaires pour les gens qui
ont pas encore
électricité dans un futur proche on va
mettre également des
sanitaires
WC si l'urgence humanitaire des premiers
jours est un peu retombé la mobilisation
ne faiblit pas affraitter autant de
camion et de matériel à un coup certain
près de 1500 € par jour sans compter les
achats de vivr et d'équipement en tout
l'association a déjà déboursé près de
200000 €. pour financer tout ça le
groupe peut compter sur la générosité
des Marocains et les dizaines de
milliers d'euros de dons spontanés et
pas seulement des cagnottes en ligne
porté par des célébrités sur les réseaux
sociaux ont permis une levée de fond
encore plus conséquente et on essaie de
donner de la force à un peu de
visibilité pour les cagnottes pour les
don de France j'ai fait des cagnottes
pour récolter un peu d'argent et ça va
ça a bien marché c'est co en fin de
matinée les camions sont remplis pris en
photo et c'est le moment du briefing
avant le départ il y a 7 positions qui
sont définies clair net et précis les
zones sinistrées sont situées à une
centaine de kilomètres autour de
Marrakech une longue route nous attend
direction le
sud s'il fallait encore le démontrer
l'une des qualités requises dans
l'agriculture c'est c'est bien la
réactivité à ville sur Ars en Champagne
la coopérative a dû effectuer ses
vendanges en 13 jours seulement en
raison notamment des conditions météo
mais au final la récolte s'annonce
excellente notre partenaire Canal 32
était dans les vignes cette semaine et
il y a goûté regardez chassnedar S a
pressuré les derniers raisins de ses 130
adhérents ce mercredi pour cette
copérative de champagne cette année les
vendangons ressemblé à une course contre
la montre pour gérer la bondance on
avait un poid des grappes moyen de de
près de 220 g contre 130 un peu plus de
130 g l'année dernière et on a eu un
phénomène d'une pluviométrie importante
au mois d'août et ensuite une vague de
chaleur qui nous a laissé craindre une
dégradation possible en fait de la
qualité des des raisins et il a fallu
effectivement faire très vite nous pour
se faire nous avions recruté une troisè
équipe au niveau des pressoirs et nous
avons fonctionné 22h/ 24 pendant 13
jours contre 19 jours l'année dernière
deux autres facteurs ont intensifié la
charge de travail l'augmentation de la
réserve pour reconstituer les stocks de
secours qui est passé de 8 à 10000 kg et
la maturité simultanée de tous les
sépages à l'habitude on commence par les
Pinau noirs puis viennent les chardonés
puis viennent les Pinau blancs cette
année il a fallu récolter les quatre
sépages en même temps cette course de
vitesse s'est répercuté à chaque étape
des vendanges de la collecte dans les
rangs de vignes lors des premières
fermentations et ici sur les quais de
collecte si j'analyse les chiffres
depuis les années 2000 c'est la première
année où nous avons en moyenne 350000 kg
de raisin qui arrivve par jour à traiter
ce qui est très très conséquent les
premières dégustations des jus sont
rassurante la complexité aromatique est
préservée malgré des poids de grappe
inhabituels et arrivé un moment en fait
la vie ne peut pas produire suffisamment
de sucre pour pour autant de de volume
de récolte de manière générale c'est une
très très jolie année à sp blanc c'estàd
que les les chardonnais sont magnifiques
ils étaient totalement sains vraiment
aucun problème selon le cahier des
charges de l'appellation les premiers
champagne issu de la vendange 2023
seront disponibles 15 mois après la date
de mise en bouteille chassen d'Ars a
choisi de les commercialiser d'ici 36
mois à une dizaine d'années pour tirer
le meilleur parti de la vénification des
raisins tout à fait autre chose dans la
nuit du vendredi 15 septembre plusieurs
greines du golf des 24 heures à mulsan
près du man ont été pris pour cible par
le groupe d'activistes écologistes les
soulèvements de la terre dans le but de
dénoncer des prélèvements d'eau
excessifs en cette période le directeur
du golf assure pourtant être sensible
aux enjeux de consommation d'eau et
avoir mis en place des mesures concrètes
d'économie reportage de Anthony pyon
pour LMTV Sart ils ont tagué donc le
premier green du 17 du 10 et du
8 Simon Boilet s'était préparé à ce type
d'action cet été plusieurs golf France
ont été visés par des militants
écologistes cette fois c'est trois de
ces green qui ont été tagués geste
revendiqué par le collectif les
soulèvements de la terre par cette
action nous dénonçons l'accaparement
illégitime de l'eau pour des loisirs de
privilégiés alors que des maréchés du
secteur se voient interdit ou limité
l'accès au captage de l'eau le directeur
du golf des 24 heur comprend mais
regrette que ces efforts n'ai pas été
pris en compte on essaie de mettre les
graines les plus miser pour utiliser le
moins d'eau possible et la deuxième
chose c'est que quand on arrive dans une
période on va dire de sécheresse ou en
tout cas de forte chaleur donc les
fairway et les départs on les on les
laisse de côté et on utilise vraiment
que le le strict minimum pour maintenir
en ville le green qui représente entre 1
à 3 % d'un golf pour preuve le directeur
nous a fourni cette photo aérienne qui
représente son golf lors de l'été 2023
par exemple la semaine dernière on a
utilisé que 70 m cube pour une semaine
qu'on a déclaré auprès de la DDT qui
nous autorise ou pas les l'arrosage de
nos grriilles Simon Boilet a aussi pour
projet de rattacher son golf à une
station d'eau usée pour préserver la
nappe quant au groupe les soulèvements
de la terre il a lancé un appel à la
multiplication des
actions sans transition je vous propose
d'évoquer notre patrimoine celui qui
fait nos territoires de retour de Riad
en Arabie Saoudite où se déroulait la
45e session de l'UNESCO la délégation de
la ville de nîes souhaite partager sa
profonde émotion d'avoir obtenu
l'inscription de la Maison Carrée au
patrimoine mondial de l'humanité et plus
particulièrement avec des jeunes
écoliers de la ville Olivier Michel
pourv
Occitanie si pour le nimois la valeur
universelle et exceptionnelle de sa
ville ne faisait aucun doute l'avir
validé par le Comité du patrimoine
mondial de l'UNESCO via sa maison carrée
avait en ce mardi matin une certaine
saveur on a un chef-dœuvre là et c'était
dommage que ça soit pas reconnu ben je
trouve que c'est extraordinaire surtout
que là la ville elle devient de plus en
plus belle donc tant mieux pour nous
économiquement parlant une labellisation
UNESCO serait synonyme d'une hausse de
fréquentation touristique de l'ordre de
30 %. construite entre l'an 2 et l'an 7
elle est le temple romain le mieux
conservé au monde mais a connu une
restauration intégrale entre 2006 et
[Musique]
véritable forum de la ville elle affiche
plus de 2000 ans d'histoire des
histoires de culte de manifestation de
célébration et d'inondation elle est
également source d'inspiration multiple
et abrita même un cinéma 3D un
classement qui intervient après 20 ans
de réflexion pour la municipalité sur
quel dossier porter devant l'UNESCO et
un échec en 2018 alors à l'autre bout du
monde le maire de nî n'a pu retenir ses
larmes de crocodil
cette décision honore nous ni moi avec
fierté et émotion que je
me rencontré au lancement de la
candidature l'élu en charge du dossier
nous avait confié l'importance que
revêtait ce classement au patrimoine
mondial c'est quelque chose
d'exceptionnel on se distingue autant
qu'un palais de versail ou les pyramides
de guisé voyez-vous on est vraiment sur
la cette liste du patrimoine mondial
mais on carré devient le 51e bien
culturel français à obtenir la
labellisation UNESCO l'occcitanie en
compte neu comme la cité de Carcasson
l'Écosse et séevenen ou encore le pont
du gare et puis autre bonne nouvelle le
mémorial de thieepeval au lieu du
tourisme de mémoire dans la Somme figure
désormais dans la liste des monuments
classés Patrimoine Mondial de l'UNESCO
au-delà du devoir de mémoire c'estet
inscription devrait aussi relancer la
fréquentation touristique de ces sites
d'exception Jérôme mouberon pour eotv
faut-il encore présenter le mémorial de
thbval érigé en hommage au soldats
britanniques tombés ici durant la Grande
Guerre oui car le monument cher au cœur
des Britanniques est désormais auréolé
d'un nouveau label celui de patrimoine
mondial c'est une page d'histoire il
faut le préserver pour
longtemps ça doit rester comme ça et
être entretenu pour toujours et pour que
les génération future puisse venir et
comprendre ce qu'il s'est passé ici j'ai
croisé des écoliers français et j'espère
qu'ils en parlent parce que ce lieu doit
continuer à vivre le mémorial de thbval
figure parmi les 139 sites mémoriel
français et belges nouvellement
labellisés par l'UNESCO à l'Historial de
la Grande Guerre voisin du Mémorial
l'annonce à de quoi ravir l'inscription
à l'Unesco pourrait bien doper une
fréquentation touristique déjà
conséquente on a eu des fréquentations
exceptionnelles pendant le centenaire
114000 visiteurs au musée à Peron en
2014 en 2018 l'ensemble des sites de
mémoire de la Somme enregistré des
tombées économiques aux alentours de 21
millions d'euros si le tourisme de
mémoire constitue une manne financière
indéniable pour les professionnels du
secteur encore faudra-t-il adapter les
services à un nouvel afflux au niveau
des des services effectivement il faut
qu'on ait l'offre d'hébergement de
restauration qui qui suivent euh alors
en plus il y a l'opportunité du canal SC
Nord Europe qui est vraiment situé à
proximité des des sites de mémoire donc
on risque d'avoir effectivement des
afflux de visiteurs qui vont aller en
constante augmentation dans les années à
venir et et donc il faudra effectivement
que l'offre s'adapte à cette nouvelle
demande durant le centenaire de la
Grande Guerre plus d'un million de
visiteurs ont parcouru les site de
mémoire de la somme un chiffre en baisse
depuis la crise sanitaire et le brexit
l'inscription au patrimoine mondial de
l'UNESCO tomba point nommée et contribue
elle aussi au devoir de
mémoire et puis pour finir ce journal on
ne compte plus les écoles qui portent
son nom c'est maintenant autour de l'air
de Garonne à Saint-Nicolas de la Grave
sur la 62 de porter désormais le nom de
Pierre P le chanteur de Castel Sarasin a
répondu aux questions d'è Grimaldi pour
la Dépêche du Midi nos partenaires sur
place sans se départir de son humour
habituel écoutez-le B je suis un peu
jaloux parce qu'il est mieux que
qui mais moi je suis heureux de me
retrouver en si bonne compagnie sur
cette autoroute entre Narbon et et
Bordeaux voilà voilà c'est la fin du
Grand J territoir on se retrouve très
vite pour une nouvelle édition au revoir
à
[Musique]
tous